what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU last night episode
6 of She-Hulk came out and so far I've
seen a lot of mixed reviews some people
like it some people don't so right away
let me know if you liked it in the
comments down below now in this episode
although it did kind of feel like a
filler episode a lot of important things
actually did happen they just weren't
the main highlights however the main
villain has actually been teased and
revealed and if you're really wondering
who the heck intelligencia is and who is
actually behind everything we'll answer
that in this video because if you start
to connect some of the dots you can kind
of see where this story is going not
only within She-Hulk but also within the
MCU as well so let's dive into the
really important things that you need to
know about this episode and talk about
who the villain could be so this episode
starts off by Jen getting an invitation
to be a bridesmaid from an old friend
she feels obligated to go so of course
she says yes now last episode we were
introduced to Luke Jacobson who designs
superhero out outfits for superheroes
and this is taken straight from the
comics as this is what Luke does in the
comics as well now it seems like Luke
has actually designed Jen multiple
outfits at this point we know he
designed her a She-Hulk suit but we know
that he also designed her a She-Hulk
kind of superhero uniform however in
this episode in the beginning we find
out that Luke also made a dress for
She-Hulk to wear to the wedding flash
forward to the wedding jyn actually
shows up as She-Hulk her old Friends
start raving over her telling her how
great she looks but of course her friend
Lulu the bride is kind of upset because
she feels like she's taking the focus
off of her and it's her big day and it's
her wedding so she tells her that she
wants her to be Jen now here She-Hulk
breaks the fourth wall like she does in
the comics talking to us stating that of
course she wanted to show up as She-Hulk
at the wedding not as just Jen which is
the title of the episode just gin this
shows us the big change in Jennifer's
mindset from the first episode to now
originally jyn rejected She-Hulk and
wanted to be just Jin but now she
actually thinks it's really cool that
she's She-Hulk and she wanted to brag
about it which is why she showed up as
She-Hulk at the wedding this is lining
up a little bit more with the comics
where jyn is actually She-Hulk for the
vast majority of the time she really
enjoys being She-Hulk in the comics now
cut back to the law firm in the
beginning Jin said because she had to go
to the wedding Mallory would have to
cover for her on a Case Nikki mentioned
that she would get to work with her and
that it's only a divorce case but then
we find out who the divorce case is for
it is for Mr Immortal now Mr Immortal in
the comics is exactly as he sounds he's
a man who can't die now Mr Immortal in
the comics is a pretty depressed guy he
actually found out that he couldn't die
because he tried to kill himself
multiple times then he realized that he
could actually use this for good he
became a superhero and was even a part
of the Great Lakes Avengers however
after not being able to die and watching
all of his friends die over time he
became massively depressed again now the
reason that he needs a lawyer is
actually quite funny Mr Immortal has
been married several several times in
the one scene in the law firm we can
actually count nine people that he was
married to the problem is and and why
it's so funny is because he didn't
actually get a divorce to these people
when he was ready to move on he simply
killed himself or made it seem like he
killed himself and he thought that this
was actually the best way to do it and
would spare their feelings the best
instead of having a conversation where
he has to explain that he doesn't want
to be married to them anymore so he
simply acts like he died and moves on
however the issue is the internet is a
real thing in today's day and age and
everybody is always taking pictures and
videos and can find you especially if
you are somewhat a superhero so all of
his ex-spouses technically not his
ex-spouses because he never got a
divorce but now they're all seeking lost
damages one of them has a son that she
had to raise alone the other one is
talking about how they spent a lot of
money on a funeral even though he really
didn't actually die so this is why Mr
Immortal needs a lawyer now ultimately
the first time we meet him Nikki really
judges him for basically being a coward
he doesn't really want to deal with it
so he just simply jumps out the window
he simply avoids this conversation like
he avoided being married to his
ex-spouses now back at the wedding we
find that Titania is actually at the
wedding Jen back in human form at the
request of Lulu sort of pulls Titania to
the side trying to be reasonable with
her saying hey this is my friend's
wedding it's very real you can't be
about our beef right now but Titania
claims that she is dating one of the
groomsmen and that she was invited
however gin sees through this and
realizes that it's just a clever roux
for Titania to try to get back at Jin
however Lulu is kind of StarStruck
because Titania is still kind of a big
celebrity so she's just happy to have
her at the wedding now from here we and
Jen meet Josh and Josh seems like a good
dude he actually is focused on jyn not
She-Hulk and Jen likes this of course
because this is a reverse of what was
happening recently when she was dating a
She-Hulk where when guy saw her as the
regular gin basically rejected her also
one of the guys that she went on a date
with Todd Mr Baywatch is most likely one
of the villains in this show which we'll
get to in just a bit I like Josh but I
think that he might actually be a bad
guy as well we'll have to to wait and
see on that but cutting back to the law
firm and Mr Immortal is actually where
we get the first mention of the True
Villain of this show Mallory asks all of
the spouses how they became aware of Mr
Immortal that he wasn't actually dead
but indeed faked his deaths then simply
regenerated one of the women says I
found it on the site intelligencia I saw
a video of him he got hit by like four
cars then got up and walked away now
this is at first kind of disguised as a
man-hating website however we go on to
find that it is much more than that and
anybody who's read the comics
automatically knows what intelligencia
is intelligencia is actually a group
made up of extremely smart villains
Modoc being one of them and we know that
Modoc is actually going to be appearing
as a villain and Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania so we start to see the
connections here the leader is also most
likely involved in Intelligentsia as
well and there's even a little bit of
proof of that later on in the episode
which we'll get to in just a bit now at
the wedding Jen ends up getting drunk
because she has nothing else to do with
the wedding and she ends up calling her
cousin and Bruce now she doesn't get in
touch with him but she does say in the
voicemail that she's been trying to get
in touch with him for a very long time
now she's drunk so she doesn't actually
know how long she says it's been months
or weeks or days so we don't actually
know but it's been some time but what we
do know is that Bruce is not on the
planet he's not on Earth he's in sakar
or he's on his way to sakhar No Doubt
setting up for his solo Hulk film which
has heavily been rumored to be based off
of a World War Hulk storyline now Jen is
still super drunk and then Titania comes
out and sucker punches her outside Jin
says I knew it and Titania basically
says of course duh I have to get back at
you however Titania doesn't want to
fight jyn just as Jen she wants to fight
She-Hulk and after struggling a little
bit to turn into her Hulk form just like
her cousin Bruce Banner kind of did in
Avengers Infinity War she finally hulks
out and pretty much wipes the floor with
Titania Titania gets embarrassed and
sees that people are recording and is
very rude to them and this is probably
not going to work out too well for her
as we know how the inner networks videos
go viral so I'm assuming there will be
some type of cancel culture for Titania
within the series which will make
Titania hate She-Hulk even more now
Mallory and Nikki hope the situation
with Mr Immortal helping his spouses get
what they all deserved they're
celebrating together in Mallory's office
when they stumble upon a deeper part A
much darker part to intelligencia you
have to make an account and the account
has to be approved so they basically
just kind of act like a bro on the
application her interests are Bigfoot
Bitcoin USA exercise protein UFOs and
the username is She-Hulk sucks now on
here we see a ton of hate for She-Hulk
we even see people asking how to kill
her and stating that she should be
killed Nikki wants to tell Jen but
Mallory says no don't tell her because
she already has enough to deal with she
doesn't need to deal with this stupidity
but of course Nikki being the good
friend that she is causer leaves her
voicemail and tells her about the whole
entire thing this is where we see her
with Josh eating french fries but see
that she is under surveillance and we
quickly realized that some organization
is surveilling her and is ready to take
her down we see the old needle that was
used to try and Pierce her skin by The
Wrecking Crew which failed and then we
see a new needle which is seemingly made
out of vibranium I would assume now
here's where it all kind of starts to
connect it's widely believed and I
assume this as well that Todd was the
member of The Wrecking Crew that
actually tried to stab gin or She-Hulk
with the needle and failed he showed up
on the date with jyn and talked about
her being a specimen he then popped up
again at her Law Firm working with
Mallory and more on her in a bit as well
but Todd wouldn't pop up again for no
reason there's clearly something going
on with Todd because there really isn't
a reason for him to be at the law firm
he was most likely there trying to get
closer to Jen and also what I believe is
to be working with Mallory the person
who tried to stab She-Hulk is also the
only member who kept a ski mask on and
we did not see the true identity of this
is pretty much a big sign that it is
indeed Todd Todd also did mention
vibranium on the date wondering if it
could actually appear Pierce her skin so
it looks like Todd was simply going on
the day to try and find out a little bit
more about She-Hulk because his employer
wants to take her down and it's
basically been revealed at this point in
this episode that intelligencia is the
True Villain of the show this was
actually reported by some insiders not
too long ago and this just confirms it
the only question we have now is who is
the leader of this organization and the
answer is probably twofold one is
actually the leader it's been confirmed
that the leader from the Incredible Hulk
is going to be returning in Captain
America New World Order it's also been
reported that there are going to be
other variations of the Hulk in the
movie as well we know that the leader
has the Hulk's blood inside of him and
transformed a little bit but is most
likely looking for more of the Hulk's
blood and who knows what he's been doing
all of this time off screen as far as a
villain is concerned he makes the most
sense right now for the main villain of
this series although I am questioning
whether or not they'll actually show him
since he is going to be the main villain
of Captain America 4 they might only
just tease him in the show and set him
up for that movie now like I mentioned
Modoc is also a part of intelligencia in
the comics and we do have Quantum Mania
coming up as well and although I do
think the leader makes the most sense
Modoc could also be behind this as well
working with the leader now as far as
Todd is concerned I'm pretty sure he's
just working for intelligencia working
for the leader and is just kind of a
normal member of The Wrecking Crew but I
think the big reveal of the show is
going to be that Todd is indeed a
villain now in the comics Mallory also
turns against She-Hulk at one point in
time and tries to take her down and I
think this could be happening in
She-Hulk as well because why else would
Todd be meeting with Mallory at the law
firm I'm assuming that they were meeting
most likely to talk about taking down
She-Hulk either that or Mallory could
just simply be an innocent bystander
here and Todd is simply using her to get
closer to Shield so intelligencia is the
leading villains of this film most
likely led by the leader and Todd is
most likely going to be the face of
intelligencia for the show so let me
know what you thought about She-Hulk
episode six I know a lot of people were
expecting Daredevil and were
disappointed that he did not show up but
we still have three episodes left so
leave your thoughts down below don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
to stay up to date on more Marvel news
and breakdowns for live updates you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof